Okay, let's go to another college.
Yes, things are fired up to date.
Okay, who else did I wanna go to?
Oh, okay, let me go to our caller from the
214 area code, who's
calling today from 214.If me Crete Chris,
who's up.
You're not on speaker Fonda.
No Hello Chris.
Alright, so I guess what I'm wondering about
David after the whole election, I don't think
there's
really a path to victory for Bernie at all
I'm kind of disappointed about it 'cause of
the student loan
debt and the healthcare crisis that we had
right now.
Yeah, but what I'm really more worried about
is, I don't think Ben really has much the
chance to be
Trump Kolkata PR conversation that you had
before as well.
I don't think he has much chance to
beat him.
Especially in states like New Hampshire.
You don't think bin will be from in New Hampshire?
I'm just looking at the primary results for
Hampshire where Trump almost got 200000 votes
and Joe
Biden was in a distant force.
Oh, okay, New Hampshire rarely decides an
election, but here's my view on this, Okay,
I get a lot
of people that call me and they say David
only Berne can be Trump only tools can beat
Trump only
Andrew Yang can beat Trump whatever.
I think 80% of the November outcome is going
to be the circumstances on the ground at the
time, if
the economy is perceived as being pretty good
if the virus is under control, it is very
difficult to
remove.
And incumbent president historically, it's
really tough to knock out an incumbent president.
I think both Ian and Bernie would struggle
to win.
In that case, if the economy is not perceived
as
good, if Trump's approval rating drops into
the mid­30s if the virus is continuing to
spread, I think,
either burn or BI would have a very good shot,
at defeating Donald Trump, this black­white
stuff
about only this person would definitely lose
this person who definitely when I'm not seeing
any data
that backs it up.
Yeah, 'cause I guess I was also worried about
other swing states like Florida, as well,
I think as I
definitely think by an...
Has a chance in Pennsylvania, because that's
where his home state is, and
who have the Home State advantage.
But I think Trump also has an advantage in
Florida as well?
Yeah, we listen.
Bernie does terribly in Florida Democrats
like bi and way better than they like
Bernie.
In the general you obviously need to pull
in independence, and some Republicans.
I don't
know the answer about Florida at this point,
but I think the black­white thinking about
this
Democrat would definitely win, and this Democrat
would definitely lose the candidate once you're
down to just...
A couple of people like we have now is only
about 15 to 20% of the outcome.
80% is
going to be...
When you're looking at re­electing a president,
it's going to be...
What is the
perception of how the country is doing at
the time?
So you really think if the cronies is still
out of control, by they may actually have
a chance of
03/13/20 Page 7 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
beating trump it and as a result and if the
economy is terrible.
Yes, I do believe I do believe that.
And just as easily it could be the opposite
and the same would apply to burning.
So what are other states that you think they
are gonna be on the radar?
'cause I'm thinking about
states like Florida, or we at the St.In testis
gonna come down to what happens in Michigan,
Pennsylvania, North Carolina, Wisconsin the
states that made the decision back in 2016.Alright,
thank you, we're gonna do this.
Or a state more upcoming.
Let me take a quick re...
If your
holdings, don't hang up because I will go
right back to
the phones
just after the